at the start of the movie we are shown
that a beautiful woman named Vera has
been held hostage by a devious man named
Robert ludguard Robert who is a plastic
surgeon by profession has been working
day and night to develop an artificial
skin that is burn resistant and can also
repel insect bites one day Robert is at
a medical press conference where he
States his theories and urges the other
doctors to join him on his research here
we get to know that Robert is a big shot
who has the support and admiration of
many people although the other doctors
believe him to be insane after the
meeting he returns home and watches Vera
from a monitor that he has installed
next to his bed he observes her for a
while but doesn't notice any movements
hence Robert rushes to a room to his
horror she has attempted the unthinkable
Robert immediately rushes her to his
medical lab and rescues her in the nick
of time after a while varagain's
Consciousness and inquires if she will
ever get to leave but the doctor remains
silent this reveals that she has been
held captive for a long time I'm
following this we are given a brief
overview of the place Robert lives in a
large Mansion which is almost isolated
from the main city he has no family or
relatives and his closest confidante is
the housemaid Marilla who apparently
knows about the hostage Vera there are
also a few other servants in the Mansion
but they are oblivious to what's going
on one day while Robert is having
breakfast Marilla gives him a gallon of
blood and reveals that she extracted it
from a live animal wasting no time
Robert takes the gallon and heads to his
lab to conduct some experiments on it
after a while he successfully extracts a
sample of artificial skin and applies it
to a dummy then he transplants the dummy
skin and puts it on Vera at last Robert
conducts numerous burn and mosquito
tests and concludes that the skin is
indeed resistant from all of them it's
not entirely insect repellent though the
doctor is still there a few days later
the manic doctor is at another press
conference where he announces that he
has successfully invented a skin that is
burn and mosquito resistant he has named
it gal according to Robert this new
invention will eradicate malaria
completely off the Earth after the
presentation he is approached by the
head of the plastic surgery Community
who inquires about how he created this
skin Robert replies that GAO is the name
of his late wife who was severely burnt
he also reveals that he combined genes
of pigs and humans to make this new skin
which is harder and much more resilient
hearing this the chief scientist is
shocked as the practice is completely
illegal and immoral hence he orders
Robert to stop his research and even
threatens to report his activities to
the board if he doesn't oblige at night
a depressed Robert walks into Vera's
room and tells her that he has completed
all of his experiments on her this
excites Vera and she asks if he will
release her but once again Robert
doesn't say anything after a while
Morelia advises Robert to dispose of
Vera as soon as possible because she
believes that Vera's resemblance to his
late wife GA might create problems
however Robert asserts that he is not
worried and orders Morelia to fire all
the servants to Vera's abduction a
secret the following day after all the
servants have left a man in a tiger
costume arrives at the door he tells
Morelia that he is her son zika whom she
hasn't met in over 10 years he does this
by showing her his ass Morelia is
hesitant at first but soon her maternal
instincts kick in and she allows him
inside but after a while when zika is
having a meal the television flashes
news about a recent bank robbery from
the news Morelia finds out that zika is
one of the escaped robbers when she
confronts him about it he readily
accepts his crime saying it is his daily
bread and butter however he also
requests her to let him stay for a few
days claiming that he has nowhere else
to go and needs to hide as the two are
talking zika sees Vera on the
surveillance Monitor and is stunned by
her physique he asks Morelia about her
location but gets no reply desperate to
find the girl zika ties his mother to a
chair and starts looking for Vera he
eventually finds her room and starts
forcing himself onto her strangely while
zika is doing so he's says that he is
surprised to see her alive turns out
that Vera looks exactly like Robert's
deceased wife gal and zika was involved
with her somehow just then Robert
arrives home and finds Marilla tied to
the chair when he checks the camera he
sees Vera being assaulted by the
Intruder Furious he rushes to the room
with a gun and immediately finishes off
zika then he holds Vera in his arms and
Promises to never let her out of his
sight again shortly after as Morelia is
cleaning the blood-stained sheets she
tells Vera that the deceased zika and
Robert were brothers although it is a
secret that only she knows about zico
was born to a construction worker while
Robert was fathered by a wealthy
businessman under whom she worked
previously this means that Morelia is
the biological mother of Robert but he
is completely oblivious to it that night
the two again meet and Vera asks Morelia
why zika acted as if he knew her Morelia
replies that he mistook her for Robert's
wife gal who looked exactly like her she
continued news that the two brothers had
completely contrasting childhoods Robert
grew up in a rich family and went on to
become a successful doctor whereas zika
grew up on the streets and became a
criminal Morelia also reveals that
Robert and his wife gal had a daughter
named Norma and the family was very
happy at one point however things took a
turn for the worse when zika arrived at
their house one day and Marilla allowed
him to stay in The Farmhouse the moment
zika saw gal they felt an instant
connection and with the days passing by
they started meeting frequently and
eventually fell in love one day they
decided to run away from Robert in a car
however Midway they got into a fatal
accident zika immediately ran away from
the burning vehicle leaving his lover
behind by the time Robert reached the
scene his wife was in a vegetative state
with her face barely recognizable
despite this Robert never lost hope and
took great care of his wife he even
removed all the mirrors from the house
so that gal wouldn't feel bad about her
burnt appearance several months passed
and gal recovered well but her once
beautiful face could not be a stored one
day she heard her daughter singing
outside a song that made her feel
emotion for the first time in years and
when she headed to the window to look
she accidentally saw her face in its
reflection and became devastated at the
sight of what she had become hence with
no willpower to continue living she
jumped out of the window and ended it
all unfortunately her lifeless body was
noticed by Norma who became traumatized
by the sight in the present Vera and
Robert have intercourse the latter
misses his wife a lot so he imagines her
and does the deed after finishing up the
two cuddle and fall asleep in his sleep
Robert dreams about his daughter's
demise in the next scene the movie goes
back to six years prior where Norma is
recovering from the trauma of her
mother's death on an evening Robert and
Norma attend a crowded party and shortly
after she mysteriously vanishes Robert
goes looking for her and as he is
walking around a guy rides past him on a
motorcycle shortly thereafter he
discovers normal lying unconscious near
a tree trunk when Robert wakes my up she
screams as if he had abused her in the
present Robert suddenly awakens in a
cold sweat turns out he has recurring
nightmares about this very incident at
the same time Vera dreams too about a
guy named Vicente who works in his
mother's boutique store Vicente has a
crush on Christina who also works in the
same store but is revealed to be a
lesbian one day he attends the same
party that Robert had seen in his vision
coincidentally he meets Norma and they
become fast friends they then go inside
the garden and suddenly start making
love it appears as if they're going to
have a great time but suddenly Norma
begins to have a psychotic break
something she's been medicating for ever
since witnessing the death of her mother
she screams at the top of her lungs and
even bites his hands this scares
vicentea a lot so to shut her up he
smacks her in the face and knocks her
out then he hurriedly fixes her clothes
and flees the scene after a week Vicente
is seen riding his motorcycle through
the woods surprisingly Robert is
following him who has been looking for
an opportunity to take revenge he soon
crashes vicente's motorcycle and
forcefully takes him to his basement
room later a cop informs vicente's mom
that they discovered his destroyed
motorcycle at the base of a cliff all
the clues point to Vicente having fallen
from the cliff leaving his mother
devastated the next day Robert goes to a
mental hospital to check on his daughter
Norma but she refuses to accept him
thinking that he assaulted her and shuts
herself inside of a closet she has
developed a fear of all men and only
cooperates with female nurses elsewhere
Robert has abused Vicente by keeping him
Chained and depriving him of food and
water a few days later Norma passes away
having thrown herself from a window just
like her mom and to escape from her
grief Robert tries to indulge himself in
work thus he prepares Vicente for his
new experiment by shaving him and taking
him to the operation theater he also
invites other doctors and creates a fake
statement of consent to perform a
vaginoplasty on Vicente here the master
Mr plan of Robert is finally revealed he
wants to transform Vicente into a female
after hours of surgery the procedure is
finally complete when Vicente wakes up
and learns that he is no longer a male
he freaks out the next day he is shifted
to a better room there Robert takes good
care of him and provides him with
medicine and other necessary devices to
make sure that his sexual organs grow
properly one day Robert reveals that he
abducted Vicente because of what he did
to his daughter the latter is scared but
he has no choice but to oblige to the
Mad Doctor's demands he hopes that one
day he will finally be released however
even after several years he is still
kept in captivity he is also fully
transformed into a female and has
undergone numerous intensive procedures
to slowly be made to look exactly like
Robert's deceased wife gal Vicente is
none other than Vera the movie then Cuts
back to the present where Morelia is
angry that Vera is being allowed to
freely roam the house Robert even takes
her on numerous shopping trips scared
that something bad might happen Morelia
warns him that he shouldn't let Vera
roam so freely but Robert simply ignores
her later that day a colleague of
Roberts comes to his home to show him a
newspaper with vicente's picture on it
he remembers conducting the sex change
on him and accuses Robert of lying about
vicente's consent but before things can
get ugly Vera approaches them and
defends Robert by saying that she indeed
gave consent to the surgery as she
wanted to be a female after the
colleague departs Robert thanks vera for
saving the day that night as the two are
having intercourse Vera heads downstairs
with the pretext of getting some
lubricating cream however it's clear
that she has other intentions she takes
out a gun from a drawer and hides it
inside her bag after Gathering some
courage she then confronts Robert and
reveals that she was just pretending to
love him Robert is speechless and before
he can say anything Vera shoots him to
death Marilla who is downstairs is
startled by the sound and she rushes to
the scene but unfortunately for her she
is also finished off in the same manner
as her boss Vera is hiding under the bed
and as she shoots her she says
peek-a-boo [__] in the final scene Vera
heads to her mother's Boutique shop
where she meets her former Crush
Christina the two chap for a while and
Vera finally reveals everything about
how she was abducted and forcefully
turned into a female she even shows a
dress from six years before to prove
that she is really Vicente hearing all
this Christina breaks into tears the
movie ends is Vera finally meets her
mother and reveals that she is none
other than her lost son she says it is
me Vicente
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching